well after we've been reporting the
Prime Minister has been raped berated
for his use of language in the Commons
last night and after he said the best
way to honor the memory of the murdered
MP Joe Cox would be to get Briggs it
done joining me now from gamma soul and
West Yorkshire is Joe Cox's sister Kim
Ledbetter thank you very much indeed for
being with us what do you think of that
statement from the Prime Minister that
the best way to honor your sister's
memory is to get Briggs it done I
watched Parliament TV for four hours
last night and was mesmerised and
dumbstruck by the scenes that that I saw
before me and I think the Prime Minister
needs to think very carefully about the
language he uses I think everybody has
to think really carefully about the
language they use and and for me this is
not a party political matter this is
across the political spectrum it's
across the issue of brexit and I've been
saying this for two years now
unfortunately I'm not sure people are
listening
I think things did reach a bit of a head
last night and I'm hoping from some of
the conversations that are taking place
this morning that things will be
slightly karma going forward in the
coming days in the coming weeks but I'm
very clear that you know we all have a
responsibility to think about the
language we use the way we treat each
other and when we speak to each other on
a human level but I'm also very clear
about is the last thing I want the last
thing Joe would want is for her name to
be used in a way that silences debate
the robust discussions that are taking
place of a vitally important and we live
in a democracy or a very lucky that we
live in a democracy where we can have
these debates and discussions but I
think there is a tipping point where the
level of civility and the level of
respect you know becomes unacceptable
and I think unfortunately we witnessed
that in the chamber last night I
understand that but just on that
specific statement from the Prime
Minister about being the best way
Tornillo sisters merit memory being to
honor effectively what the seventeen
point four million voted for three and a
half years ago I mean that of itself is
not incendiary
he wasn't the one who introduced your
sister into the debate what what do you
think of that specific claim because
after all we know that Joe was an
alliance builder who wanted to work with
other parties and getting out of the
European Union wouldn't that be an
alliance a compromise well I think the
point he was trying to make if I'm if
I'm being fair is that the best way to
to bring people together is to find some
sort of solution to the problem that we
face I think and I hope that's what
that's what he meant and it's very
difficult for me to be objective about
it when Joe's name is used I think he he
probably got it wrong I think the
Homburg comment was was wrong and I
think to use Joe's name in that way was
wrong and what I hope is he has some
time to reflect on that and think about
it but I think the point he was making
and again I always try and be objective
I was trying to be fair about these
things is is that people want an end to
this chaos and I and I agree with him in
that respect you know it's very
difficult it was a very heated debate in
Parliament last night you know you could
feel the tension you could feel the
passion that was there and under those
circumstances people do make mistakes I
hope he has some time to reflect on on
what he said and and and realized that
possibly it wasn't the best thing to say
under those circumstances the
organizations you set up in memory of
Joe are about conciliation what's your
what's your thought on what we do about
Briggs it with quite clearly the country
still divided down the middle on this
question goodness me I wish I had the
answer to that I wouldn't be sat here
well dad we said we start somewhere far
more important than good muscle but and
I think we have to find a way forward
and ultimately that is going to come
down to compromise you know I think back
to our child and how Joe and I were
brought up and compromised as a big part
of that it's about listening to each
other it's about understanding different
perspectives not becoming entrenched in
our own positions I think that's the
only way we're going to find a way
forward and as we do that we have to do
that with respect for people who
disagree with us and that's what we do
through the work of the Joe Cox
foundation it's about understanding
difference it's about appreciating
difference
embracing it but doing so in a
respectful manner and ultimately coming
down to the fact that we do still have
things in common you know as joe said in
our famous speech it's very easy to
forget that and I think the humanity of
being in public life is what's what's
lost at the moment and we need to pull
pull that back you know it's a very
difficult job I sympathize with mp's
they've got a really really difficult
job to do
but I think also what we have to do is
is they have to take responsibility for
their actions as well and some of the
behavior we've seen across the political
debate I'm not a member of a political
party I don't have a political
allegiance I think you know everybody
whatever your colors are wherever you
are on break is it you have to think
about how you move forward from this and
listen to each other you know and I've
seen I've seen people you know calling
other people out who behaved as badly
themselves you know so I think that
that's that's my main point if I had
that the answer to Broca's it I'd be a
very rich woman wouldn't a Brava so
thank you very much indeed